you said not everyone
can be a party member of the communist
party in china there's 1.3 billion
people in china what percentage of the
country 90 million
there's 90 million okay so that's what
one percent what is that
it's less than one percent okay 90
million 90 million on what
a 1.4 billion no no it's not one percent
guys 90 million 99
no it's not no it's not on one billion
on one bill 1.4 billion yeah i know 90
million on 1.4 billion is like six and a
half percent that's what you're talking
about
six point five percent ten percent
that's about one
ten percent of one point four billion is
140 million yeah 90 million it's
probably six and a half years
that's why we got a human calculator
here we always appreciate that you're
saying
that's a big number still yeah but so 95
percent of the country is not
part of the communist regime in china so
just break that down like how do the
people so i mean
you can uh just go to xi jinping i think
it took
five or six times to join the party i
mean
you you sent me the bull you made the
comments send me the bull it's like
it's like tony and the mafia you don't
you don't like get made the first time
that's right right you have to keep
working at it and you have to
demonstrate your loyalty that's
that's the system they have and they
have the ultimate omerta
you know the ultimate america when
you're talking you know what omerta is
like when you swear
you pay the oath you pay the oath you
cannot break silence you cannot tell
anybody every mafia asks yeah
to say you know the mafia exists like
when they interview meyer lansky
does the la cosa nostra exist what's la
cosa nostra
you know when i spend the whole day with
sunny francis and like sunday so what do
you know about meyer lansky
good guy what can you tell me about
lucky luciano another good guy
what can you tell me about ben siekel
phenomenal guy
john sonny these guys killed a lot of
people yeah i don't know what you're
talking about oh yeah
that's a party 100 yeah the ultimate
omerta and the reason why there's the
ultimate omerta
is why what's the ultimate alberta
the the thing that china can get away
with that the
italian mafia eventually couldn't get
away with is what the ultimate omerta is
if you break silence we don't come after
you
kill your whole family of course so i
dare you to say something
because the reality is you ever heard a
secret with somebody and you shared it
with another person like let's just say
you heard something you're like
oh something happens you're like oh my
gosh let me tell you what i just find
out you know you tell your wife
you tell your husband you tell your kids
like do you know what just happened
right this just happened no way yeah you
broke the alberta
yeah you broke the oath but in china you
can't do that you can't do that can't
even tell you why and
and and what what guys will always do
they'll all they'll always
default to you know i'm not gonna say
anything i'm gonna go i'll go to prison
for the rest of my life
but what you're talking about is you're
letting your family continue to
to to live their life right that's
that's really what it's about
but but more than that pat it's
it's it's more than that it's about
owning the bank
they own the bank of china so imagine if
the mafia
owned the fed and what they could do
at one point we're trying to if they
would have done that
i mean think about it if the if the
mafia owned the fed
how would this country be different are
you kidding me
you don't you can't say anything you can
control anything you want
anything you want they're taxing
everybody and anybody
you make a list of the top earners and
you just make one phone call right
so who who wants to do financial
services in in china right now
probably only the people that are
involved with the government no goldman
sachs jp morgan morgan stanley are
fighting like cats and dogs to get in
there to do financial services they want
to get into bed so
what happened with ddd what happened
with dd so dd
this is great can you pull this up so dd
gets a 4.4 billion dollar ipo
now what is dd for people that don't
know so dede i and i use it when i was
in china
it's like uber and if you remember uber
was making great inroads same as tesla
i love this stuff to watch these guys
these entrepreneurs go in there and they
think they can
take over china like i've got a
different approach like i'm going to go
yeah
why would they even think that's an
option so uber goes in there and what
happens
didi takes him over so dee dee is like
the chinese uber china uber
and lyft put together except think about
what didi can do now didi can collect
all this information they've got cameras
in the cars they're collecting
information about data right data data
chinese communist party wants that data
and
so what happens is they have this 4.4
billion dollars ipo
so jp morgan goldman sachs morgan
stanley are like pushing this they're
making millions of dollars on the
the on the ipo what's his name jim
cramer you got to be invested in dd
we as soon as the ipo closed and they
got that 4.4 million dollars into the
bank of china
the chinese communist party said okay
we're going to take the app off
everything
and we're going to basically who owns dd
the chinese communist party
why they take an app off everything
because they want to control the data
that dd has
the chinese communist party wants to
control the data go back to that article
so but but here's the deal they were
going to do that anyway
but but the party said okay let's get
this four billion dollars
first and then let's basically take
control of didi right so
what's happened what happened during the
dunk shopping era is you had these
private companies rise up
and you had these billionaires come like
jack ma for example
same thing with dd well dede comes up it
it gets this ipo and then the chinese
communist party knows they're going to
shut down
dd because they want to take control of
the data
and they but they let the ipo happen so
who whose money is in that ipo
who's money not jp morgan investors not
not goldman sachs not morgan stanley
it's
it's retirement funds it's it's people
for a living in this country the chinese
communist party are deliberately
stealing
from the american people the people who
work their ass off every single day
and the guys that are helping them push
these these these
equities goldman sachs jp morgan morgan
stanley
here's a question for you and by the way
where did and this is
uh you you may not know this where did
jay clayton come from the last sec
chairman what did he do i don't know
goldman sachs
what was his big deal claim to fame what
was it
alibaba ipo wow i mean if you don't
understand how wall street and dc
and the chinese communist party create
this trifecta
to control our financial system to the
detriment of the american people
and for the benefit of the chinese
communist party
then you don't understand what's going
on you're going around looking at life
like the matrix right you're like oh i'm
living my life and i'm eating chicken
you know but it's you know it's it's all
fake so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye